We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. Today's voicemail caller is making
a very, very serious accusation against me.
Take a listen to this.
Hey David.
Uh, I can't help but feel a little bummed
out about the whole interests on voting process.
Uh, I mean, I think option two the best and
uh, I really liked the song so I went back
to the video to listen to it again today and
I realized that you had edited the youtube
video to like make the quality lower on the
song.
And I don't know if that's like really unfair.
Yeah, obviously.
And you know, it's just a psychological fact
that people usually only remember the first
and last items in the list.
Then you clearly like put number two second
to make people not remember it.
I don't know why I have this bias against
it.
Like my friends said that they preferred number
two as well.
Listen, we it would not even occur to me to,
but by the way, I don't do the editing to
say to pat, listen, go back in and reduce
something to make this particular song sound
bad because I don't want people to like that
song that we don't have the time to do this.
It would never occur to me to do something
like that.
We did nothing of the sort, just not a lot
of people like number two and your thought
that most people like the first or last thing
that they hear that's not true.
We had six songs and most the the plurality
liked song number four which is right in the
middle, so you're wrong on the facts.
You're wrong about the assessment and I take
personal offense to the allegation that we
would do anything like that.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the five industries being
hardest hit by Trump's China tariffs.
At least a couple of them might surprise you.
We will also talk about a reusable bag that
a study found makes people think and users
of this bag are gay, which makes no sense,
but we will talk about this study and I will
also tell you about, I have alluded to this
before, I'm going to talk about the problems
with MRIs for low back pain and the sort of
garden path into the medical world that it
will often open at very limited bit to very
big, to very limited benefit, better said,
uh, to the patients.
And I've talked about this a little bit before,
but now we actually have some significant
data about it.
So that's all on the bonus show.
There's two ways to get the bonus show, become
a member@jointpacman.com if you like the regular
show, you will like the bonus show.
So sign up if you don't want to become a member
and why you wouldn't is beyond me.
But imagine for a second someone didn't want
to be a member.
Become a patron for at least five bucks a
month, and you'll get access to that same
bonus show at patrion.com/david Pakman show.
It's great
to be back from the holiday weekend, a very
packed week with some very special guests.
I will have to announce a little bit later
on this week, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.